hey yo intended catch here and this time
today is a video we're gonna be
finishing up
our ufc sports betting model from
scratch project
um but before i start this video i
wanted to show you a little thing i
found
uh from twitter and basically it's
adding a little nicer
readme file onto your github profile
so um i saw it from i guess monica she
had a nice tweet about it and then she
also has a website
i'm kind of displaying how to do it so i
wanted to show you
um my readme that kind of elevates my
profile and it's just a simple
um markdown document with the repo name
under your username so i'm definitely
check it out um it's pretty cool
this readme or this little profile
section literally took me two minutes to
make so
um i think it makes it a little bit
better and i think it's something that a
lot of people on github
aren't aware about so just something to
show
um also before i start this video um
next week will be my one year
anniversary uh for with the
tuesday project so i figured i'd be
finishing up season one
of the tidy tuesday series uh with a q a
so
i'll also have a q a submission form
uh linked below under the description so
you can ask me a question
for that video okay
so let's actually go um over from what
we started from
for our previous video about the feature
engineering and modeling
so i actually finished up the modeling i
did the evaluation
and we actually found that um the xg
beast models performed the best compared
to the other models
i tried out a few random forest models a
few pca regression models etc
and the xg boost models seem to perform
the best that's pretty good
um one of the things i actually had to
do was build a pipeline
um and one of the problems i actually
faced was i was kind of uh
i was kind of being lazy with the actual
modeling
so for example um all of our actual
submission metrics or our actual
head-to-head metrics
that we created was through our feature
engineering pipeline
and we essentially just hard coded these
features um what i actually wanted to do
is basically have
those types of feature engineering
basically embedded
into our recipes so that's what i
basically did i used
our models that we made in my previous
video
and basically changed out the recipe so
that we have our actual
um a head-to-head metric so we have our
strike differentials our strike favor
abilities
um whether the or not the opponent's
favored using the ewo scores
etc so that's one thing i added
um it's it looks like a lot of code but
i started just copy and pasted
on the code from our feature engineering
so nothing too crazy
and nothing really changed um they're
essentially the same models
um but it adds a little bit more to our
pipelines
so yeah nothing too crazy i just did
that i also saved all the models to our
little
modeling folder right here so we have
about was it six
models um our five models that model out
the components
then a final outcome model okay
so let's actually go to the final part
of our project which is actually kind of
like
showing it to other people and letting
letting people actually use our models
so i'm going to open up our app
and here's the app i'm gonna run the app
first before we actually go over it
okay there we go and then we have our
shiny dashboard
app um it's a pretty simple um dashboard
it's only three tabs
and two of the tabs we've already really
made um
so not a lot of code this app actually
took me about
i think three hours on sunday i mean a
lot of it was me
um doing other stuff um
such as writing some other scripts and
stuff like that so we have our little
dashboard right here
and we've added plotly where where i
thought it would be most beneficial so
we have our
number of outcomes um for our fights by
type we have our ego distributions um
using plotterly
and we have the fighter with the highest
ego score
for that given weight cost in the
history where you can highlight it and
it'll show you the name
weight class eos score etc so joanna
um again for charlotte flyweight and
then for featherweight amanda nunes
bantamweight amanda nunes welterweight
george st pierre etc
so that's pretty cool um you know you
can do some highlighting too
um and stuff like that i also have used
some gg ridges to show
basically the percentile um distribution
of
all of the um metrics so we can see our
knockdown
um distributions are pretty similar
across the different weight classes
and then with significant strikes landed
we can see that you know
um women seem to have a little bit more
um higher distribution
or more skewed um distribution
where um they have a little bit more
higher output for significant strikes
landed
right same with strikes landed and again
with submission attempts to take down
attempt uh takedowns landed are pretty
much the same across the classes
and then we have a little bit of like a
top five
um outcomes our top five components so
who which fighters have the most knock
downs
most amount of segment strikes landed
total strikes landed
uh total sub attempts etc and we also
have total wins
um so yeah pretty pretty um good like
kind of summaries of all the weight
classes
i haven't added any filtering to it um
just because i wanted to focus mostly on
the modeling
okay so now we have our actual
um probability or model probabilities
where the people
using this dashboard can actually use
the models that we created to predict
outcomes through to hypothetical fights
so one of the things i wanted to do was
okay let's show maybe um conor mcgregor
where's conor mcgregor and well actually
we can probably type this into conor
mcgregor
um uh versus like
dustin oops one
dustin poije and one of the things i do
want to add is like a little button so
it doesn't do
the um predictions um all the time when
we can just like choose our fighters and
then press
um the button uh but i didn't get to it
so we can see that um conor mcgregor has
a 20 chance of winning
and we know the outcome of the fight
where justin poyer actually ended up
winning
um since we actually have a recent fight
um recent title fight um that we
observed i guess
last saturday which is gilbert burns
versus kumar uzman
um kumar uzuman and ended up knocking
doing a tko two
two gilbert burns on the third round um
one of the things that gilbert
one of the things that kamaru was
talking about was he wanted to have
a challenge um uh he wanted to challenge
who was it um
jorge masvidal so i think that'd be kind
of interesting to basically um
do a hypothetical match up so let's just
do
uh kamaru so with kamaru
uh
uh mario uzman versus
uh jorge
jorge mas vidal jorge
as vidal right even though we know that
kumar guzman has already beaten hora and
maz vidal let's actually see the
unpredicted fights and we can see the
kamaru movement has a 77
percent chance that our model is
predicting or uh to win the fight
pretty cool i'm gonna do one more thing
because i think it'd be interesting to
see stephen thompson
uh fight kamar guzman let's see if it
changes so it gives the camaro who's
been having a 67
chance of winning against stephen
thompson as you can see the margins a
little bit more tighter
so for me i think that'd be a more
interesting fight to see
um because i actually like steven
thompson a lot as a fighter
okay um i also added one more feature
which is the upcoming car predictions
i've essentially just scraped
um the five uh future cards and then
basically you
apply the model towards all the fights
that were available um
and i thought that would be pretty
useful especially if someone's gonna use
this dashboard you know they wanna
um not just having they don't wanna have
to like enter in each fight
in our little um fight predictions um
tab instead we should just have
um the actual our upcoming cards and the
probabilities and stuff like that
so i used the table um and we basically
outputted the probabilities
um i actually scraped these cars on
friday um because i wanted to get that
done
so i scraped the cards and then started
building pipelines on sunday
so we can see the predictions for the
camaro using gilbert burns fight
uh when you see the macy barber or
zillexy rosso you might also see that
we have these little intervals we have
the lower
the predicted and then the upper
probability probabilities of the fights
and one of the things i found that was
kind of interesting which makes sense
was that if i predicted kamaru reason
versus gilbert burns
and then also did gilbert burns versus
kumar easement so we swapped out the
fighters and opponents
the probabilities didn't actually line
up one-to-one they weren't exact
compliments of each other
but they followed the um actual um
trajectory you know
is it above 50 or below 50 pretty well
so what i actually did was basically
just average them out or took the medium
between the
probabilities and then use the upper and
lower limits
between the two fighters probabilities
um
as the lower upper elements so we kind
of have some intervals
which i think actually adds a little
more um information about the model's
predictions
we also have our average round um
estimations
of the components that these models are
predicting
so we can kind of see why we this model
is thinking that quantum reason
will essentially be gilbert burns um
with a high amount of certainty because
the gilbert uh because the model
believes that kumar easement will have
way higher significant strikes way
higher strikes landed
and um a little bit higher takedowns
even though it's essentially
estimating pretty low submission times
and takedowns um
it's really thinking that kamaruzan
would just have more well basic outs
right gilbert burns
uh which actually ended up happening so
i think that's uh uh pretty interesting
again against macy barber versus alexa
grosso we can see that these intervals
are pretty tight
compared to relatively to come out using
cover burns we're still giving
alexa grasso the edge about a 58 to 42.
uh and but we can see the intervals also
kind of clash with each other
but we can actually see why um our model
is saying that elected rosso should beat
macy barber
is because they think um alexa grosso
will have
some edge in the significant strikes
landed and also strikes landed
um it also thinks that the submission
attempts at takedowns are pretty similar
maybe that alexa rosso has a little bit
more takedowns than a macy barber
um so that's pretty interesting uh one
other thing that was a little odd is
actually
really under um predicted kelvin
gastelum
with um ian heinich that's pretty
interesting too
and then it also mispredicted uh ricky
simmons vs brian keller
um but it gave the probabilities of ryan
keller beating ricky salmon
in a pretty tight interval so i'm pretty
fine with that
lastly we have the actual probabilities
in a little potly
with the intervals so we have you know
thiago uh thiago santos versus um
alex alexander uh rakitch and we see
like this is
um santos uh they think alexander
rakitch will win
but we can see how the probability
intervals
kind of overlap right whereas opposed to
kevin gassom and ian heinich
uh our model really messed up a lot and
basically was really under um predicting
a kevin castle uh maybe i could see why
um it's predicting that but that's what
it's saying
so i may because uh kevin gaslin has
been on a loss
a loss streak and that's why it's under
uh predicting it
okay so let's actually go over the
higher level thing of our app
um most of the actual um
logic is actually in the modules because
i wanted to i actually ended up
modularizing
a lot of the components but we can kind
of see you know we just load in our
packages
our data um we have three menus
again nothing too crazy um we have our
modules that i created so
an outcome plot elo plot component plot
best plot
i'm nothing too crazy again um and then
we can actually go into server functions
uh one of the things i actually really
ran into a problem with which actually
wasted a lot of my time creating this
app but i kept on running in errors
where
i wanted to basically make modules for
these selectors
but i kept on running into some issues i
don't know if it's because i was trying
to use these
modules within other modules and
reactive
variables or i probably just need to you
know add a little function or do
something different but
i kept on running that error so i ended
up just hand coding
these inputs and stuff like that uh not
sure why
it wouldn't work for me but it's
something i ended up doing and i think
that's fine
uh for what i did then we had this
reactive function which is basically
on this reactive variable that is
basically the meat and potatoes of our
actual predictive
um tab so with giving a
selected fighter and a selected opponent
it basically combines all that model
data together
and then we have our fighters data and
then our opponent's perspective so
with a fighter opponent we have our fire
component and then for the opponent
component it essentially switches them
together
um so we have the opponent's perspective
that way we can get two different
probable
sets of probabilities and then finally
we kind of combine them together
to get the outcome okay which will do
the actual prediction
i'm using our little helper function
that i imported
and again we have these little boxes
that basically selects
the average probability of winning the
average probability of
losing because it's all from the
perspective of the fighter
right now we have our servers again
nothing crazy
we just have our little id and then our
input which is our data frame
so if you actually look at this um if
you actually look at this app
it's actually a very simple app um and
it's pretty easy to read i think if you
are a beginner and are shiny
you kind of get an idea of like what was
going on um pretty easily and i think
this is a very clean app that i wrote
not trying to pat my own back but let's
actually go over the
modules which is probably the bigger
things
um but again it's not too crazy um
i basically loaded in all my models from
here um one of the problems i actually
had
um with sharing this um uh
this uh i guess repo or project was that
the models got really large because i
usually
would put it in one entire mod um rds
object
or like final models which is like all
six models and one little rds
but it was too large for me to upload a
github so i just uploaded them
independently
or individually one thing i probably
would change
is actually uh use butcher to remove
some of the excess
space that was in there maybe to make it
a little bit thinner so i could upload
it together
um but yeah so we have our actual
outcome um modules right here
um you know just using ggpot and
ggplotly um
i also would wrap in our my ui with a
box
so that way it's a little bit more
cleaner um
but most of it was actually the uh let's
see here
um our fire components so in the fire
components we actually predicted
we it would return a table with the
predicted um
component outcomes and then again we
would use that same data frame
and kind of replace it uh right there so
we have our fighter and our opponent
components using our opponent and our
fighter
and then finally it would basically just
combine um
those fighter and opponent um uh
predictions
predict using our outcome model and then
summarize it getting the average lower
average uh probabilities with the upper
and lower bound
okay so nothing too crazy
okay so that's basically it for this
project
i i know that um this app seems pretty
it you know for all the work we did
i'm actually displaying it was pretty
simple um to do
um and that's kind of what i wanted to
do really i wanted to make this into an
app
and one of the things i would like to
add i'm just kind of doing a little
self-reflection on this project was
maybe adding more um report style stuff
so
i think in improving the ui of it so
with fight predictions
adding you know maybe some plots of like
oh like
here is the fighter's profile picture
maybe also like right on this fighter
prediction so i give you the expected
um components and show the other
fighters expected components
right there but the main things i would
really change with this project is
not necessarily the dashboard because i
think all dashboards can be improved
right maybe remove that little
underscore to a space stuff like that
but
think about the actual model itself
there are a lot of things i would change
with it so
one of the things i would change with
the model um that i really didn't have
time with is
uh basically calibrating the model
probabilities
so one of the things i wanted to do um
because this essentially was supposed to
be about a ufc sports camping model
was assess the model probabilities
towards like a money line
and convert that money line to a
probability and define a custom metric
for it
right so one of the things that we want
to do is make sure our model
is essentially at the op at the um more
severe end
of the probability so essentially like a
meanwhile gloss
using that that sports camera
probability so
if a sports scam wing um money line is
saying that
you know alan belcher has a 70 percent
chance of winning
and then alan bellshire actually ends up
winning we want our model to basically
be more certain that on the
allen bellship will win so that way it
can
so that way we actually understand that
our money line that our model is giving
is a can have a little bit more margin
um
can can give us a little more um return
in our
in our picks uh because it you know we
were willing to choose
uh the end of the bet uh more with more
certainty
stuff like that so i have something to
calibrate the probabilities
um while considering the sports gambling
probabilities of a money line or some
american odds
is something i would like to add um the
big thing is i need to get some
uh money lines and odds and spreads from
a ufc site and also be able to join it
with my data set
uh which i haven't got to yet um one
other thing i would like to improve this
model
is see how removal of certain samples
would improve the model so
one of those things i added which i
think is artificially
increasing the error of my models is
using
all of the data you know one of the
things i i think is
important to understand is it's better
to have high quality data than
a lot of data um usually so one of the
things it's always predicting is
it's having inputs where we don't have
any
data about our fighter right because
it's their first fight we don't have the
past three fights
we don't know how their total fights
it's all zero except their ego score is
1500
which is like the default score so using
that
and just filtering out like hey if the
fighter hasn't fought once
uh maybe we should remove it and see how
that improves our actual
you know validation um accuracy or a
technical validation root means greater
and stuff like that
um so definitely considering that for
our models would definitely improve it
that i think would at least improve it
additionally doing some more um
uh you know post hocs on our models so i
think one thing that would be
interesting
model is adding about like why
is our model predicting uh
that you know alan belcher is gonna have
three knockdowns for that
fight right so adding some type of lime
model
into our dashboard would be kind of
interesting to see um
just on why it's predicting it and maybe
even adding some things where we can say
like
oh well our model is saying um this guy
or this fighter is going to have this
many strikes because his
of his past experience or his past um
you know three fights where
it was just an anomaly but maybe we want
to actually tweak that independent
individual component and just like
decrease a little bit manually
and then put it into our model or our
outcome model so having that kind of
like fine tune
feature where we can you know have a
person
uh who actually understands the context
of the fight make some adjustments to
our input data for our outcome model
could actually improve it and add a lot
of functionality
and add a lot of interactiveness to this
dashboard
but um with that being said um i really
enjoyed this project a lot um i thought
it was pretty fun and hopefully you guys
liked me kind of going over my approach
to these projects and stuff like that
so i'll see you guys next week for my q
a video i'm very excited for that too
and uh
yeah tidy on